[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
les propongo un ejercicio muy sencillo
tómense unos segundos para imaginarse
una casa
ahora bien levanten la mano quienes
imaginaron el frente de la casa
y ahora levanten la mano quienes
imaginaron alguna habitación en
particular o el patio de la casa
menos mal que nos falló
ocurre que hay una gran similitud en
como imaginamos esa casa y la imagen que
tenemos de nuestro propio cuerpo
es decir
la mayoría se imaginó el frente la
fachada
como que ponemos el foco en lo externo
en la mirada exterior lo mismo pasa con
el cuerpo por lo general conocemos
nuestro cuerpo mucho más por fuera que
por dentro y la mayoría de nosotros
tenemos una imagen corporal que
corresponde al espejo
nos conocemos mucho más por delante que
por detrás
en nuestro organismo existen
una serie de receptores que nos van a
dar una información acerca de cómo
percibimos todo
nosotros interpretamos la realidad en
base a la información que obtenemos
pero en nuestra cultura
esa información la obtenemos
fundamentalmente de la vista y no
necesariamente del resto de los sentidos
nuestro cerebro sabe lo que pasa afuera
gracias a los cinco sentidos pero la
vista generalmente es prioritaria al
resto
si nosotros no tenemos una utilización
variada y equilibrada de los cinco
sentidos es probable que tengamos una
interpretación de la realidad parcial
el cuerpo cuenta con una serie de
receptores esos receptores
se van a encontrar también en nuestro
interior se denominan interceptores nos
dan información de lo que nos pasa
adentro estos receptores se van a
encontrar en diferentes órganos como
puede ser el corazón los intestinos los
vasos sanguíneos etcétera y nos cuentan
de cómo nos sentimos de que lo que nos
está pasando cuando tenemos hambre
cuando ya estamos satisfechos cuando
tenemos sueño o simplemente cuando
tenemos un malestar o un dolor
por suerte también contamos con
receptores que están en todo el cuerpo y
forman parte también del esqueleto como
pueden ser las articulaciones los
músculos los tendones los ligamentos
estos receptores se denominan propios
activos propiocepción es decir es la
conciencia de lo propio estos receptores
todo el tiempo están enviando
información y se encuentran en una red
de tejido conjuntivo que nosotros
denominamos sistema facial por lo tanto
este sistema facial claramente funciona
como un órgano sensorial
a tal punto es así que podríamos decir
que somos más sensibles por dentro que
por fuera
lo que ocurre es que
nosotros en la actualidad podemos
observar como dos extremos opuestos
por un lado gente que se mueve muy poco
sedentarios que pasan muchas horas del
día sentados o en una mala postura que
comen mal que respiramos más o menos
etcétera por otro lado en el otro
extremo están los atletas los
deportistas de alto rendimiento que se
mueven de más no sólo se mueven de más
mucho sino que muchas veces sobrepasan
sus propios límites
con respecto a esto tenemos que entender
que si bien son extremos opuestos y muy
diferentes hacia la vista comparten una
característica en común ambos extremos
carecen de la capacidad de reconocer y
sentir lo que pasa en su propio cuerpo
básicamente lo que no tienen es
conciencia corporal
esa conciencia corporal los kinesiólogos
decimos que está adormecida y que
simplemente hay que estimularla
hay que despertar la si
esa falta de conciencia corporal va a
generar en nuestro cuerpo compensaciones
y viendo hay un ejemplo si existe una
persona cualquiera si es deportista
tenemos un ejemplo que en alguna parte
de su cuerpo tiene falta de movilidad
puede ser la zona dorsal quizás pueda
generar por esa falta de movilidad que
el resto del cuerpo compense con exceso
de movilidad
por lo tanto es una situación complicada
porque ese exceso de movilidad a través
del tiempo y si esa persona sigue
trabajando haciendo sus actividades o su
deporte corre el riesgo de empezar a
tener síntomas
los síntomas es como si fuera una alarma
la alarma del coche un llamado de
atención pero hay un problema los
síntomas a veces nos engañan porque
aparecen en un lugar diferente a donde
estaba la causa a donde esa parte del
cuerpo donde verdaderamente era el
origen del problema
entonces acá hay un problema bastante
complicado porque técnicamente tendremos
regiones del cuerpo sin movilidad con
otras regiones del cuerpo que van a
sufrir y van a generar síntomas
cuál es el síntoma más común
fuerte el dolor el dolor y qué hacemos
cuando aparece el dolor
utilizamos todo el arsenal terapéutico
que existe para apagarlo para
silenciarlo para que desaparezca
cuántas veces utilizamos medicinas
medicamentos u otras para tratar la
lumbalgia cervicalgias todas las algias
o incluso una simple acidez de estómago
un proceso de constipación
permanentemente estamos tapando síntomas
que en realidad nos están avisando que
en el cuerpo algo estaba funcionando mal
quiero aclarar que me refiero a síntomas
crónicos no a un síntoma agudo como
todos sabemos que existen y que hay que
tratarlo de la mejor manera que se pueda
síntomas crónicos esos que se repiten
muchas veces en nuestra vida hasta el
punto se repiten que prácticamente
estamos acostumbrados a convivir con
ellos y hasta nos parecen normales y
quizás muchos de nosotros ya hayamos
encontrado alguna excusa para
justificarlo como la edad la más común
de todas
es decir esos síntomas van a estar
dándonos una señal de alerta y nosotros
de manera inequívoca los apagamos quiero
dejar en claro entonces
que los síntomas no es una mala palabra
y que deberíamos tener otra relación con
ellos otra interpretación claramente el
dolor es una segunda oportunidad que nos
da el cuerpo
si no existiera el dolor muchos de
nosotros y algunos deportistas los
buenos estarían muertos porque pasan
sistemáticamente al límite de lo físico
y ellos no saben cuál es ese límite por
eso son buenos
el tenis es un ejemplo de esto
el tenis ha evolucionado mucho
ahí tenemos un ejemplo como de dos
personas de dos deportistas de élite
mi máxima admiración al deporte de élite
como siempre son únicos son distintos el
deporte ha evolucionado todos los
deportistas evolucionan todo el tiempo
pero tienen una característica en común
si hablamos de tenis que es de lo que
entiendo voy a decirles que la
biomecánica sigue siendo la misma
en qué consiste la biomecánica del tenis
muy sencillo sin querer aburrirlos hay
que transferir fuerzas desde el piso
hacia la raqueta
es decir imagínense como una cadena con
diferentes eslabones esos eslabones van
a ser el tobillo la rodilla la cadera la
zona media el hombro y todo el miembro
superior va a transferir fuerza para
generar potencia en los diferentes
golpes si ese deportista tiene una
dificultad en la movilidad de cualquiera
de esos eslabones por donde tiene que
transferir fuerza quizás no se entere
hasta que le aparezca el síntoma pero el
síntoma va a aparecer en un lugar a
distancia alejado de dónde está el
problema
muchas personas incluso familiares y
amigos me preguntan por qué haces como
kinesiólogo viajando con deportistas
como si un anduviera solo paseando algo
de razón tienen pero lo que ocurre es
que todavía no está claro el alcance que
tiene nuestra profesión de kinesiología
a nosotros nos relacionan con la
enfermedad y la persona ya operada pero
en realidad si la kinesiología tiene
otra incumbencia y esa incumbencia se
llama prevención
cuando me preguntan qué hacemos
acompañando el ocio siempre contesto lo
mismo los cuidamos
porque curar es cuidar
y nosotros a estos fenómenos lo que
hacemos es cuidarlos como con prevención
es decir priorizamos la salud a
cualquier resultado deportivo y esto que
parece muy suave no saben lo que nos
cuesta nos cuesta salud a nosotros
mantener la prevención
yo estoy convencido
que el cambio
es la educación
y creo que muchos de ustedes van a
coincidir con esto pero qué tipo de
educación
solo la educación tradicional que nos
hace mucha falta o quizás una un poquito
más holística más integral
en qué asignaturas del colegio vamos a
aprender a conocer nuestro propio cuerpo
a saber cuidarlo a tener a desarrollar
la conciencia corporal a desarrollar la
conciencia psico emocional a entender
qué nos pasa porque nos sentimos mal
porque reaccionamos como reaccionamos la
conciencia respiratoria poder oxigenar
nuestro cuerpo y tener vida
claramente tenemos que hacernos una
pregunta
si nosotros seguimos pensando que el
yoga la meditación o la acupuntura son
terapias alternativas
estamos equivocados tenemos que estar
convencidos que la bicicleta es el mejor
medio de transporte que hay hay países
donde andar en bicicleta stop y acá
pareciera que sólo la usa el que no
tiene auto su invierto mucho tiempo en
el consultorio explicándole estas cosas
a la gente consideró que es educación y
también entender y ser conscientes que
el confort no necesariamente es sinónimo
de progreso
es importante quiero dejarlo en claro
que el ser humano todos ustedes están
pensados y diseñados para movernos y
para el bienestar lo que ocurre es que
el estilo de vida actual que tenemos
va en contra de las leyes de la
naturaleza del movimiento humano
entonces cabe esta reflexión que es
estamos dispuestos a cambiar nuestros
hábitos de vida y abandonar los viejos
hábitos
miren lo mismo que ocurre con la casa
ocurre con nuestro cuerpo cuantas veces
ustedes han dicho hoy voy a arreglar la
casa la voy a limpiar la voy a poner
linda porque vienen visitas como si
tenerla limpia y ordenada para que
vivamos nosotros no nos fuera suficiente
con nuestro cuerpo hacemos lo mismo nos
empezamos a cuidar cuando nos enfermamos
cuando ya están golpeando y esta es una
verdad que me cuesta decirla la salud es
una prioridad
pero solo cuando la perdemos con mis
pacientes con nuestros pacientes tenemos
un trato no no escrito que hoy lo quiero
compartir con todos ustedes
prueben un mes si no están conformes les
devolvemos sus viejos hábitos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]